yeah yeah  queen she's six  just quite eight been age four queen h4  yeah that looks terrible  and the publisher goes bishop c1 he's  sort of yeah he doesn't think he's  better there and he's waiting for rook  g8 and then  and fabian  yeah  arbiter  he's not happy about it but he couldn't  see anything better  yeah we have  it's interesting that it's not that uh  napo is like saying okay you played  rupjet okay it's a draw i know they do  it was weird they kept studying it like  you can't count till three but  i'm not sure it's threefold  and draw  let me switch on the computer i want to  know what happened here yeah let's see  if uh if after bishop b2  so rook c2 bishop f5 ef says black is  better like -1 rook g8